[Musica]
[Applauso]
Buonasera Buonasera a tutti Grazie mille
per per questo invito e per questa
opportunità di parlare di un tema che è
un tema quello dell'uguaglianza che
molto spesso viene trattato da un punto
di vista
ideologico valoriale filosofico anche
religioso ma difficilmente da un punto
di vista scientifico e scientifico di
tipo psicologico Forse perché in tanti
casi la psicologia non avendo
materialità si ritiene non abbia
concretezza di fatto quello che
cercheremo di vedere insieme in questi
minuti è come esistono dei meccanismi di
funzionamento delle persone che sono
assolutamente paragonabili a quelli che
sono i meccanismi di funzionamento del
corpo quindi
meccanicistici e uguali per tutti
cominciamo a fare un esempio facciamo un
esempio proprio con il funzionamento del
corpo allora tutti noi sappiamo che il
nostro corpo è composto di vari apparati
e che ognuno di questi apparati svolge
una funzione
prendiamo per esempio il meccanismo
l'apparato digerente il meccanismo della
digestione tutti noi sappiamo che quando
introduciamo nel nostro corpo un
alimento
esofago stomaco intestino cooperano e
collaborano tra di loro per scomporre
l'alimento trattenere quelle parti
dell'alimento che diventano energia da
distribuire al resto del corpo ed
eliminare le parti tossiche o inutili
questo processo è fondamentale perché
l'organismo possa sopravvivere e
sopravvivere in buona salute la stessa
identica cosa avviene da un punto di
vista psicologico ed emotivo con
l'elaborazione dell'esperienza
attraverso le esperienze noi acquisiamo
quelle competenze che ci consentono di
essere maggiormente adattati
all'ambiente Questo è un processo che
avviene da un punto di vista psicologico
emotivo e fisico attraverso la
cooperazione di una serie di aspetti
differenti della nostra psiche che
consentono al nostro patrimonio
esperienziale di diventare qualche cosa
il nostro possesso
tutto questo sui tre canali cognitivo
psico emotivo e fisico assolutamente
allo stesso modo tendenzialmente Noi
siamo portati a dare moltissimo rilievo
a quella che è la cognizione siamo
portati a pensare che comprendere un
evento sia sufficiente per acquisirne
quelle che sono i suoi aspetti
fondamentali e quindi tendenzialmente
per poter utilizzare quella che è
quell'esperienza per divenire
maggiormente adattati all'ambiente non è
proprio così accanto alle informazioni
cognitive che ci arrivano da
un'esperienza Noi abbiamo tutta una
serie di informazioni psicologiche
emotive e fisiche che ugualmente
necessitano di essere elaborate che
ugualmente necessitano di andare
incontro a quel processo di
scomposizione esattamente come avviene
per la digestione
questo processo È un processo che noi
ritroviamo uguale in tutti gli individui
indipendentemente da quella che può
essere la loro età la loro sesso
l'appartenenza culturale sociale anche
indipendentemente da quella che è
l'etnia quindi che sia un bambino di 3
anni un uomo di 50 piuttosto che un
afroamericano nel suo paese di origine
tutti noi tendiamo a
svolgere un'elaborazione dell'esperienza
attraverso questi tre canali e
attraverso una scomposizione che vede Le
differenti parti del cervello cooperare
e collaborare tra di loro può accadere
qualche volta che l'esperienza non
vengano elaborate che qualcuna di queste
esperienze non vada incontro a questo
processo di scomposizione e che quindi
in qualche modo resti all'interno delle
nostre reti tutta
come un unico magma un unico blog Così
come noi possiamo pensare a accade a un
cibo che non abbiamo digerito Quando
questo succede se teniamo il paragone
con il cibo tendenzialmente siamo
portati inizialmente ad avere un qualche
segnale di malessere successivamente a
dover utilizzare le nostre risorse e le
nostre energie per risolvere quel
problema il cervello però non funziona
come lo stomaco il cervello ha una
potenzialità enormemente maggiore e
quindi può aggirare quell'esperienza non
elaborata e arrivare Comunque a svolgere
quelle che sono le importanti funzioni
che consentono la sopravvivenza che gli
consentono di dare diversi comandi al
resto del corpo per poter poi procedere
ad eseguire quelle operazioni respirare
far battere il cuore nutrirsi che
appunto permettono all'individuo di
sopravvivere
Che cosa accade però immaginiamoci un
circuito elettrico un circuito elettrico
in cui a un certo punto c'è un corto c'è
una parte di questo circuito che non
funziona più bene se il sistema
elettrico è molto grande io posso
pensare come può essere il cervello io
posso pensare di far passare
l'informazione attraverso un'altra
strada però resta un'area problematica
resta un'area che richiede comunque
un'attenzione resta un'area che richiede
una parte di quell'energia che dovrebbe
essere dedicata allo svolgimento di
questa operazione
immaginiamoci poi che avvenga un secondo
corto e quindi accanto a quest'area ne
abbiamo un'altra Ecco allora che le
potenzialità a disposizione di
quell'individuo si riducono e piano
piano piano quelli che sono le energie a
disposizione per l'elaborazione
dell'esperienza dell'attività della vita
quotidiana si riducono progressivamente
un po' quella sensazione che le persone
possono riferire quando dicono che non
riescono a concentrarsi che hanno la
testa troppo piena non perché stanno
perdendo le loro facoltà Ma perché le
loro energie sono su qualche cosa che
non sta funzionando come dovrebbe e che
richiede la loro attenzione da un punto
di vista come ci dicevamo
psicologico emotivo fisico e cognitivo
ignorare questi segnali ignorare queste
fatiche è esattamente come ignorare il
mal di stomaco quando pian pianino
Comincia a diventare più preoccupante
quando da mal di stomaco si trasforma in
mal di testa quando ci rende faticoso
persino camminare
occuparsi quindi di quella che è
l'equilibrio e la salute psicologica
emotiva in termini di elaborazione delle
esperienze È fondamentale perché il
processo che governa il nostro organismo
possa aiutarci ad essere costantemente e
continua adattati all'ambiente
questo abbiamo detto Vale per tutti
indipendentemente dall'età dal sesso e
dalla provenienza Notiamo però poi delle
nelle persone delle differenze Perché
alcune persone pur avendo alla base i
medesimi processi si comportano in modo
diverso Questo dipende dalle circostanze
ambientali prendiamo due semi identici
della stessa pianta è facilmente
intuibile che quel seme se viene
piantato in un terreno fertile dove gode
di aria di luce e di acqua a sufficienza
potrà diventare una pianta rigogliosa
Mentre se lo inseriamo in un terreno
arido con poca luce e magari niente
acqua piano piano sarà portato
addirittura ad andare incontro alla
morte
le esperienze quindi e la loro
elaborazione possono essere pienamente
affrontate anche grazie a quelle che
sono le competenze che ci derivano
dall'ambiente nel quale Noi siamo
inseriti quindi essere inseriti
all'interno di un ambiente che consente
di mantenere le energie tutte le energie
a disposizione sulle attività della vita
quotidiana e quello che ci permette di
accrescere maggiormente la nostra
capacità adattativa e quindi di
proseguire in quella che è poi anche
l'evoluzione della nostra specie
sappiamo bene che gli individui
maggiormente adattati Sono poi quelli
che hanno Maggiore possibilità nella
loro esperienza di vita anche di
riprodursi E questo vale per tutti
indipendentemente abbiamo detto da
quelle che sono le loro origini
da questo punto di vista io trovo che
osservare quelle che sono le esperienze
di persone molto diverse da noi
attraverso lo sguardo del funzionamento
meccanicistico ci possa dare la
possibilità di sviluppare nei confronti
di queste persone un reale sentimento
empatico perché quello che loro stanno
affrontando e che loro stanno vivendo È
esattamente quello che noi potremmo
vivere se ci trovassimo in quella
situazione
Io spero di avervi dato qualche piccolo
indicatore qualche piccolo elemento per
poter guardare a quella che non solo la
nostra realtà ma quella che è
l'esperienza anche di persone molto
diverse da noi un pochettino diverso
Grazie
[Applauso]